In a devastating bit of news, it was revealed
on November 20, 2022, that Supernatural actor
Nicki Aycox died on November 16. Aycox's
sister-in-law, Susan Raab Ceklosky broke the
news in a Facebook post that the 47-year-old
actor and musician had passed away, writing,
Aycox was diagnosed with leukemia in 2021,
but her cause of death has not
been revealed as of this video.
Aycox is perhaps best known
for her role as Meg Masters,
the original host of the Meg
entity in The CW's Supernatural.
"You killed those two people for nothing.
Baby, I've killed a lot more for a lot less."
She was a prolific actor who appeared in a
number of high-profile projects over the years,
including the psychological thriller Perfect
Stranger and the horror film Jeepers Creepers2.
She also had a role in the second X-Files
movie, The X-Files: I Want to Believe,
making her one of the few stars who have
appeared in both Supernatural and The X-Files.
Nicki Aycox's talents as an actor were evident
to anyone who saw her performances on screens
big and small. The people who worked
with her have also been quick to note
that she was quite an exceptional
person as well behind the scenes.
Supernatural boss Eric Kripke wrote on Twitter,
"Lackluster men."
Supernatural regular Jim Beaver also shared
his memories of Aycox on Twitter, writing,
Other people associated with Aycox's work, like
The X-Files: I Want to Believe screenwriter Frank
Spotnitz and fellow Meg actor Rachel Miner,
have also posted their own condolences.
Aycox retired from acting in 2014. The following
year, she released her first and only album,
Red Velvet Room, which contains five
original songs created by Aycox herself.
Thanks to her far-reaching work in the
entertainment world, Nicki Aycox has
collaborated with a laundry list of well-known
creatives. In doing so, she's amassed a sprawling
fanbase that wraps around the world, who've
come to appreciate the work she put in when
the cameras were rolling. With the news of her
death at the forefront of the media, fans came
out in droves to honor Aycox's legacy in the form
of heartfelt social media posts. One fan Tweeted,
"I'm Meg."
Someone else tweeted,
Yet another fan noted how especially devastating
Aycox's passing is due to its close proximity
to those of fellow pop culture icons
Kevin Conroy and Jason David Frank.
This is just the tip of the iceberg when it comes
to online tributes dedicated to Aycox. Evidently,
she left a lasting impact on
folks from all walks of life,
and her death will not be an easy one for
many to process. She will be sorely missed.